حسنًا ، تعال إلى الجانب الذي تفعله
جيدًا ، فمن المؤكد أنه يمنحك
بعض الشيء مثل يا إلهي ، لا أستطيع أن
أصدق أن هذا حدث وتم
التقاطه بالفيديو ، المرأة على
لوح التجديف هي Malia Tribble وهي
في منتصف المحيط تقريبًا في منتصف الطريق
خلال رحلة 80 ميلاً من جزر الباهاما
إلى بحيرة وورث بيير ، وهو حدث
يجمع الأموال لأبحاث التليف الكيسي ،
كنت أفعل
شيئًا ما وشعرت بقليل من النقر
على لوحي  لكنني اعتقدت أنني كنت
ألتقط أمًا من الأعشاب البحرية التي تحدث أنه يمكنك سحب
الأعشاب البحرية على زعنفتك ولكن في هذه الحالة
لم يكن لوح التجديف الخاص بها هو الزعنفة الوحيدة في
الماء ، فالزعنفة الأخرى تخص
سمكة قرش رأس المطرقة تتبعها ، رأيت
وجه زوجي ووجهه  رأيته يخبر
القبطان بإغلاق المحرك
ثم يرشدني إلى القارب ،
وبمجرد أن فعل ذلك علمت أنه
سمكة قرش ،
إنه أحد تلك الأشياء التي يجب أن
تثق في الأشخاص الموجودين حولك.
قادم استمر في القدوم وعرفت للتو أن
أستمع لأه نكات زوجي أنها كانت
المرة الأولى التي استمعت فيها إليه
في حياتي تقول تريببل إنها بقيت هادئة
طوال الوقت فقط ركزت على
الحفاظ على توازنها والعودة إلى
القارب والابتعاد  من سمكة القرش
رأسه تحت لوحك يا رفاق رائعون ،
شكرًا لأنني رأيته بمجرد جلست
لأنه عاد إلى أسفل
اللوحة وغريبًا بما فيه الكفاية أنه في الواقع
نظر إلي نوعًا ما أقسم أنني رأيت عينه
هناك  هذا بعد
استراحة قصيرة مدتها 10 دقائق ، عادت ماليا مباشرة
إلى لوحتها وانتهت من الرحلة
تمامًا مثل الوقوع في داخلك ،
فأنت لا تجلس هناك وتتعثر
من الوقوع في الداخل ، عليك فقط الاستمرار في
الحركة وأمها  أفضل طريقة
للمضي قدمًا